alors justement faire un petit tour de
table par lâcheté qui par lâcheté a déjà
évité une bagarre de peur de se faire
défoncer j'ai pris une grosse claque ce
jour la rue des rosiers je plante le
décor change en train de livrer je
rentre dans la rue je bloque la rue 6h30
le gars klaxons déjà je descends énergie
m'a fait peur avec son klaxon jeux
dessins énervé avec des gestes si tu
fais quoi tu te crois où là les gens y
dort mal de klaxonner le ghailani milan
à sortir de sa voiture
le mec de la ligne verte je prends
conscience qu'il est 6h30 du matin il
n'y a pas de témoin il va me fracasser
qu'est ce que j'ai à gagner à bagard et
que ce mec-là hilson dit on a un
problème tous les deux si on n'a pas de
problème j'avais juste te dire que
j'allais me garer m'a dit que j'étais un
gros la chambre et y avait personne pape
témoin de froid fait c'était encore
tulle et une cape ya du monde mais de ta
vie n'est pas là que j'ai honte de la
raconter
wen a régné alors ici des ions devrions
alors j'étais en voiture garée quelqu'un
est devant il y avait un gars qui
m'énervait un peu aux klaxons klaxons et
jacques dans le rétro il me fait un
petit geste alors moi je fais lire c'est
un peu con fait je fais pas j'en ai bien
ceinture genre ceinture de sortir mais
vous enlevez vous votre ceinture de
pantalon
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il va finir après oui il va finir il a
un côté droit prévale finir après parce
que j'étais en voiture à l'entrée de
l'autoroute de l'ouest il ya un type qui
me fait une tête à queue incroyable
queue de poisson subtil espèce de
saloperies enfin une bonne chose mais on
imagine il se sort de la voiture et je
suis devant un malabar
c'est à dire rien qu'avec un doigt un
envoi à l'hôpital voit comme ça il me
vient une idée géniale et puis je crie
poussez-vous pourriture et j'assume
blonde
mais votre ceinture
je le vois je me donne le regarde je
vois que dans le rétroviseur il me
regarde avec un petit air de défi
ouais j'avais sature pas ce que ça
marche bien surtout quand c'est une
personne âgée ou à quelqu'un de très
jeunes loups la fenêtre il me fait ça
pardon pour ça et vous fait sa pub à
cette fois ci mon sang ne fait qu'un
tour jure c'est vrai j'étais jeune
j'étais fou fou bave je sors de la
voiture
ma soeur aussi et il est plus costaud
que moi
pas dur mais voilà non il est costaud
ouais mais avec un pas à l'époque ouais
mais j'aime pas je suis costaud mais pas
ma peau ma mére bref c'est passé pour la
vitrine moi je suis passé très vite et
il vient vers moi et s'approche vers moi
et alors que j'ai eu peur je partis en
courant au boutte sms qu'il a failli
payer là ce soir il a fait non pas du
tout il a pris un caillou et il a cassé
mon pare-brise d'injures ça c'est vrai
ah ouais amitié avec ça parce que du
coup c'est là que nolwenn a fait le
titre a cédé grâce qu'elle est là
excusez mon pare-brise c ur wech attendu
qu'il soit prêt pour que pareille date
avec marine chez carglass non avec la
même nom mais sinon normalement ça
marche très bien le web
c'est une belle histoire c'est tout je
crois qu'on va on en a eu qui par
lâcheté a déjà plaqué une personne par
sms au téléphone
bon bah merci à jean michel meyer a
toutefois fait des sms groupés
dans ce cas il me plaît à retardement
elle real à vannes de la ceinture alors
âgé kg qui par sms mais c'est plus par
par délicatesse qu'autre chose
lorsqu'en sûr quand on quitte en face à
face on dit les mots là la file un peu
secoués parce qu'évidemment il s'y
attendait pas ne le souhaitait pas et du
coup après une fois qu'on est parti elle
essayer de remettre les mots dans le
bonheur nérac au sacré casse tête c'est
quand on écrit au moins elle peut le
relire dix fois vingt fois bonjour comme
ça c'est ça les mots sont bien concours
delphine vous si un jour vous quittez
raymond vous allez envoyer un télégramme
s'appelle roger bonvin viennent ici les
noms mais qui a déjà moi je suis bien où
je suis pour les textos parce que je
trouve que quand tu vois quelqu'un pour
lui dire que c'est fini
des fois tu as tendance à revenir un peu
sur sa décision et là ça repart un peu
en anneau nanette vous vous remettez
ensemble alors que site envoie un texto
au moins tu sais que c'est fini c'est
horrible c'était le téléphone mais oui
parce que j'avais 17 ans donc forcément
les textos ça n'existe pas
elle est au téléphone savez le téléthon
prenez comme ça s'avère avant d'appeler
quelqu'un il est 18h tu veux la paix à
19h tu commences il ya des neuf écoles
et donc vous appelez la personne donc
avec 17 ans j'ai cru de superman lynch
et le dessin message en disant non
vraiment est trop bien pour moi comme on
dit toujours thème les gros singe en est
d'être aux petits et thème des tout
petits culs et moi j'en ai un moyen gros
donc définitivement on n'est pas fait
pour s'entendre et j'espérais qu'il
allait me répondre mais non mais c'est
pas vrai je t'aime comme tu es et tout
et tout il m'a répondu oui finalement tu
as raison vous écoute de la wcs
[Rires]
autant dire quoi vous avez fait quoi
vraiment ça ne veut rien dire alors je
vais vous dire ça ne veut rien dire non
[Rires]
j'appelle pas j'en vois pas de message
de black d'irak ligne ont terminé vous
infinie parce que si je quitte quelqu'un
ce qui m'a fait quelque chose de grave
showa si l'on vous quittez personnes non
non non non si ça se passe bien pour moi
qui tu es bon écoutez moi c'est lui et
vous vous faites comment vous faites
comment alors arrêtez de bois moi je
m'en vais renouveler l'émission prit la
route et ça votre vie mais pas les gens
vous adore les fans vous adore sur les
gens vous adore qui par lâcheté a déjà
donné un faux numéro de téléphone à un
mec ou à quelqu'un à tous les jours
merci tous les jours dit ma mère
voilà et enfin qui par lâcheté a déjà
embouti une voiture garée et s'est barré
sont laissé de mot ça c'est vrai ça
c'est ça s'est bien passé pour moi j'ai
pas fait ça mais on me l'a fait trois
fois déjà
déjà sans laisser de m'avez-vous avec
toi t'es tu retrouvé direct c'est pas
trois fois dans la même rue ça nous est
arrivé mais récemment dans les mois
précédent là vous êtes sûr que c'est pas
une personne qui vous vous en veux pas
je me demande très franchement oui et
alors la quatrième fois will personnes a
laissé un mot donc on l'a appelé ouais
je lui ai dit ça fait quatre fois elle
m'a juré que non mais je me demande je
me demande vraiment si celle tout cas
votre erreur était d'avoir mon père mais
il faut alors j'avais 21 ans je vais
livrer le bistrot d'amélie poulain à
montmartre et je veux et je prends mon
virage je viens juste d'avoir mon permis
je viens juste d'avoir mon camion et
j'arrache une voiture sur le côté une
114-104 z un truc comme ça il ya une
vieille avec un caniche jeudi vous
inquiétez pas madame j'ai semé
coordonnées je vous jure que c'est vrai
j'ai marqué désolé j'ai pas fait exprès
j'ai laissé sens par brice les symboles
j'ai valeur un engin car on a une boucle
d'oreille jaune là bas j'en ai perdu 9
non moi j'ai eu à faire c'est à dire que
l'été dernier sur la plage accès sans
pouvoir j'ai endommagé sans le vouloir
l'essuie-glace d'une voiture et donc
j'ai mis dessus vous pouvez me joindre
sur isabelle morini-bosc vous pouvez me
joindre à thème numéro en pensant pas du
tout qui est le lendemain j'ai eu au
moins 70 appels de gens qui elle-même a
récupéré le numéro c'est pas celui de
l'apa la bagnole en revanche est
vraiment sénat y voit un numéro un truc
il rappelle fernand widal a été bien
beau témoignage
[Applaudissements]